schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute live
die korona maßnahmen lockern oder weiter
vorsichtig bleiben das ist aktuell die
frage und wenn man auf die bundesländer
schaut dann sieht man dass dem ziemlich
unterschiedlich beantwortet wird da gibt
es also die einen die wollen noch warten
und wollen den regeln festhalten und
dann gibt es die anderen die tatsächlich
jetzt schon anfangen zu lockern darunter
auch schleswig holstein dort gilt
beispielsweise ab morgen die 2g regel im
einzelhandel nicht mehr und die korona
warnstufe wird gesenkt und das trifft
auch noch auf einige andere bundesländer
zu und das bedeutet dann auch dass es
keine sperrstunde mehr gibt zum beispiel
in schleswig-holstein oder das in den
geschäften eben keine masken pflicht
mehr herrscht oder beziehungsweise nur
noch masken pflicht mehr herrscht das
ist das für wichtige detail das habe ich
hier gerade durcheinandergebracht und
das ganze gilt dann ab morgen und wir
können also heute zu diesem thema
sprechen zu dieser debatte und
diskussion unter anderem mit heiner garg
von der fdp ist der gesundheitsminister
in schleswig holstein und ist uns jetzt
zugeschaltet und eure fragen und
kommentare an ihn und zu diesem thema
gerne im stream schönen guten abend herr
gab hallo schöne frau jungherr gab jetzt
haben sie sich zu diesem schritt
entschieden in ihrem bundesland da soll
also ab morgen tatsächlich zweig im
einzelhandel fallen nur noch masken
pflicht wie kam es dazu dass sie sich
jetzt dazu entschieden haben da jetzt in
diesem bereich zu lockern
wir leben seit zwei jahre in einem
ausnahmezustand und der ausnahmezustand
ist vor allem dadurch gekennzeichnet
dass wir seit zwei jahren massive
grundrechts einschränkungen als eines
der haupt mittel des pandemie management
ergriffen haben und auch ergreifen
mussten und wir haben inzwischen in
schleswig holstein
eine impfquote bei der bevölkerung
diejenigen die 18 jahre alt und älter
sind von 90 prozent die also vollständig
geimpft sind nach derzeitiger definition
wir haben eine quote der geposteten die
bei dem 60 jahre alten und älteren
menschen bei fast 85 prozent liegt und
vor dem hintergrund weil sie zweig im
einzelhandel ansprachen war hier die
koalition vollkommen unserer auffassung
dass wir nicht länger erklären können
dass eine maßnahme von der wir
inzwischen wissen dass der einzelhandel
mitnichten ein pandemie treiber ist eine
maßnahme die in vielen bundesländern von
gerichten inzwischen gekippt wurde warum
wir die ausgerechnet doch aufrecht
erhalten sollen da haben wir gesagt das
ist ein richtiger erster schritt uns von
2g im einzelhandel zu verabschieden
dabei der masken pflicht zu bleiben weil
ich glaube dass wir nach zwei jahren
pandemie uns ernsthaft über die frage
unterhalten müssen wie wollen wir
eigentlich weiterleben wir wissen dass
das virus nicht einfach irgendwie
verschwinden wird wir haben inzwischen
impfstoffe von denen wir auch wissen
dass sie die so genannte sterile
immunität zwar nicht werden leisten
können aber dass sie vor schweren
krankheitsverläufen schützen und wir
haben erste antivirale therapien wir
müssen die menschen darauf vorbereiten
aus meiner sicht dass wir von einem
pandemischen zustand den wir die letzten
23 monate alle miteinander erlebt haben
mit all den auswirkungen die das ja
nicht nur
auf das gesundheitssystem hatte sondern
auch auf unsere gesellschaft auf das wie
wir unsere freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung empfinden diese diskussion
von diesen pandemischen zustand in einen
so genannten endemischen zustand zu
kommen wo wir lernen müssen als
gesellschaft mit diesem virus zu leben
wie wir mit erregern leben von denen
ungefähr sechseinhalb 1000 von denen wir
wissen gibt das wird eine große
herausforderung und hier müssen wir
schritt für schritt die menschen auf dem
weg mitnehmen und ich kann den menschen
in schleswig holstein nur noch schwer
erklären warum im nachbar den elan
dänemark so gut wie gar nichts mehr an
corinna maßnahmen also an einschränken
maßnahmen gilt obwohl beispielsweise wir
beim boostern sogar ein kleines bisschen
vor den dänen liegen und gleichzeitig
unsere krankenhäuser seit wochen zwar
selbstverständlich kroner patientinnen
und patienten haben aber die belastung
der krankenhäuser auch von all
denjenigen die seit zwei jahren mit uns
zusammenarbeiten als mäßig bezeichnet
wird
dies hat uns dazu gebracht dass wir
einen ersten schritt übrigens immer noch
im rahmen der beschlüsse der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
dass wir diesen ersten schritt
miteinander gehen wollen und die
diskussion aber anstoßen wollen und auch
anstoßen werden wie wir von einem
pandemischen in einen indischen
zustandekommen der
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach der
hat genau davor bedenken was passiert
wenn man jetzt also schon lockert und
hat sich dazu auch geäußert wir haben
mal kurz rein
wir können also breite lockerungen wie
sie derzeit diskutiert werden zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht vertrieben
nicht wundere mich über die diskussion
die zum teil in der politik jetzt zu
beobachten ist wir werden natürlich dort
nicht vor ostern öffnen können aber wenn
wir jetzt schnell öffnen dann verlängern
wir nur die welle und schadet uns selbst
sie teilen diese bedenken nicht also ich
würde das abschaffen von 2g im
einzelhandel und das zulassen von
chorproben unter zweig plus bedingungen
sowie das zulassen von proben von
blasmusik orchestern auch unter zweig
plus nicht als breite lockerung
bezeichnen ihn übrigens stört mich der
begriff lockerung des wegen der klingt
so als hätten wir es irgendwie mit
untertanen zu tun denen wir jetzt gnädig
wieder ein stückchen freiheit gewähren
das ist ja ganz anders wir müssen doch
jeden tag diese grundrechts
einschränkenden maßnahmen wirklich gut
begründen sie müssen verhältnismäßig
sein und deswegen finde ich es ist der
richtige weg jetzt darüber zu
diskutieren
übrigens auch mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister das tun wir in
der gesundheitsministerkonferenz
ja zum glück regelmäßig aber wir müssen
diesen ersten schritt gehen im ersten
schritt in richtung normalität und wir
müssen hier miteinander einen weg finden
wie wir möglicherweise auch mit etwas
unterschiedlichen geschwindigkeiten in
den ländern genau unsere bevölkerung
darauf vorbereiten dass wir mit dem
virus werden leben lernen müssen das ist
unglaublich schwer das ist mir klar aber
wir dürfen gerade diese diskussion nicht
scheuen ist es vielleicht mit der
schwierigste mit die schwierigste phase
der pandemie überhaupt
seit tagen kritisiert ihre partei auch
den lkw chef lothar wieler dabei geht es
darum dass er den genesenen status
überraschend ohne absprache eben auf
drei monate verkürzt hatte auch da hören
wir kurz rein bevor wir darüber sprechen
können
fdp chef christian lindner kritisiert
die fachliche und die kommunikations
entscheidung lag in den händen von
hennweiler und ich glaube man darf sagen
dass das außerordentlich unglücklich war
der designierte fdp generalsekretär sei
sagte des vertrauens der fdp ganz sicher
wieder auf grund dieser neuerlichen
verfehlung die ja leider keinen
einzelfall darstellt nicht mehr sicher
sein
der gesundheitsminister hat luther
wieder da trotzdem klar sein vertrauen
ausgesprochen
es klingt jetzt aber tatsächlich nicht
mehr so einheitlich zwischen jetzt spd
ampel innerhalb der ampel mit ihnen mit
der fdp
versuchen sie sich da jetzt auch ein
bisschen so abzugrenzen gerade als fdp
ich versuche weiterhin vor allem in
schleswig-holstein
ein erfolgreiches panini management in
einer jamaika koalition zu betreiben und
ich glaube wenn man die zahlen in
schleswig-holstein sich anschaut während
der gesamten pandemie über in der regel
deutlich niedrigere instanzen als der
rest der republik und extrem hohe
impfquoten im vergleich zu den meisten
anderen bundesländern
dann sind wir hier schon ganz ordentlich
unterwegs und zuhören wieder bzw zum rk
ii da muss man einfach sagen wir haben
noch in einer
gesundheitsministerkonferenz mit dem
neuen bundesgesundheitsminister
miteinander besprochen dass es eine
präzisierung beim genesenen status geben
muss diese präzisierung wurde auch den
kolleginnen und kollegen angekündigt
dass man den begriff sechs monate in 180
tage präzisiert und dann gab es quasi
über nacht
die 90 tage und zwar vom rk ii
festgelegt und ich will das gar nicht in
der sache kritisieren das mag ja
fachlich sogar richtig sein aber bei
einer frage die tausende oder
zehntausende menschen betrifft und auch
deren grund rechtsausübung zum teil
betrifft
da kann eine nachgeordnete behörde nicht
einfach über nacht bei eine entscheidung
treffen von der selbst der
bundesgesundheitsminister überrascht war
die kommunikation war hier
hundsmiserabel ich finde das muss man
auch sehr klar sagen sehr klar benennen
und wir brechen uns alle kein zacken aus
der krone weder gesundheitsminister noch
politikerinnen und politiker noch
behördenchefs wenn sie fehler einräumen
und das war ein kommunikationsfehler ich
will mal sagen wir mussten in den
letzten 23 monaten in dieser pandemie so
viele entscheidungen treffen und ich bin
überzeugt davon dass nicht jede
entscheidung die wir getroffen haben
auch jede entscheidung von der ich sage
die ich getroffen habe war bestimmt
nicht jede richtig dann gehört es dazu
dass man diesen fehler einräumt und
miteinander guckt wie man das besser
machen und ich glaube wirklich dass bei
der kommunikation luft nach oben ist wir
reden von grundrechts einschränkungen
von menschen und da kann man nicht
einfach mit einem federstrich dass über
nacht ändern das hat ganz viele menschen
verunsichert das hat auch viele menschen
verärgert und ehrlicherweise als
vertrauensbildende massnahme der politik
in anführungszeichen hat das jetzt mit
sicherheit nicht gedient insofern teile
ich die verärgerung meiner partei voll
und ganz mir ist es jetzt dran gelegen
also wohl mit dem bund als auch mit den
länderkollegen und länder kollegen denn
bei uns landet die wut und der frust der
bürgerinnen und bürger vor allem
zuallererst mit denen eine lösung zu
finden wie man aus der kiste wieder
vernünftig rauskommt sie sprechen ihre
länderkolleginnen und kollegen an und da
wirkt sie aber tatsächlich so alt macht
jeder jetzt gerade so ein bisschen
science also wenn man da jetzt auch
überlegt wie er einheitlich das
eigentlich ist befürchten sie nicht dass
es da vielleicht auch zu mehr verwirrung
kommen könnte eine frage und beispiel
hätte ich bei ihnen heißt das im
einzelhandel gilt jetzt nur noch masken
pflicht heißt das was für eine maske ft2
ist dann nicht erforderlich wie aber in
nachbar bundesländern oder wie ist das
zu verstehen weil wir haben in schleswig
holstein die ganze zeit gesagt beides
geht sowohl die sogenannten op masken
also die blauen oder grünen mussten die
jeder kennt die medizinischen mund
nasenschutz geht genauso wie eine fb2
maske wir haben damit die ganze pandemie
über gute erfahrung gemacht und sie
sehen ja dass die ankündigung sei es das
nördliche nord westlichen nachbarland
mecklenburg vorpommern sei es hamburg
überall wird angekündigt dass die zwar
im einzelhandel fallen wird und insofern
sind wir da im norddeutschen verbund in
niedersachsen musste ein gericht g2
kippen das ist bei uns nicht der fall
gewesen ist normal das ist eine maßnahme
die würde ich nicht als dramatischen
öffnungs schritt bezeichnen sondern das
ist eine anpassung
und ein erster schritt ein bisschen
zurück in die normalität ja interessant
ist natürlich nur trotz allem wenn es
dann unterschiedliche trotzdem auch nur
noch aber unterschiedliche regeln gibt
aber was mich auch nochmal interessieren
würde auch eine sache sie hatten nämlich
im januar selbst auch noch ein bisschen
sorge geäußert vor der omicron variante
dann hatten sie sich dass sie das eine
große herausforderung für die kritische
infrastruktur
das war also noch im januar und hatte
neben gesagt auch bei der bewertung der
situation sei es eben wichtig auf die
personalsituation in den kliniken zu
schauen die eben angespannt sei und die
sich verschärfen könnte das war so ein
bisschen ihre befürchtung im januar
woher kommt denn ihr optimismus jetzt
was hat sich geändert ja wir sind in
schleswig holstein gemeinsam mit hamburg
und bremen die ersten drei bundesländer
gewesen bei denen die omikron variante
schon um weihnachten herum die
dominierende variante war und ich glaube
zu dem zeitpunkt kann man sehr klar
sagen wir wussten alle nicht ganz genau
was kommt da eigentlich noch zusätzlich
an belastungen zu es gab erste anzeichen
aus anderen ländern aus dem vereinigten
königreich aus den ostküsten staaten der
vereinigten staaten
dass die krankheitsverläufe milder sein
aber gleichzeitig natürlich die pure
infektions anzahl also die tägliche
anzahl an neuinfektionen schon dazu
führen kann dass kritische
infrastrukturen allein deswegen
betroffen sein könnten weil viele
menschen im quarantine sitzen und
wir haben deswegen noch einmal eine
nachjustierung und zwar in richtung
verschärfung der maßnahmen in
schleswig-holstein vorgenommen und wir
haben in den letzten fünf wochen also
seit jahresbeginn zum glück gesehen dass
sich bei der belastung der kliniken dass
das kann man sehr schön sehen wir haben
um das mal an einem beispiel fest zu
machen wir haben seit sechs wochen um
und bei 300 bis 350 patientinnen und
patienten insgesamt hospitalisiert und
davon sind immer zwischen 35 und 50
patientinnen und patienten auf der
intensivstation
hierbei den intensivpatienten patienten
rund drei viertel wegen einer krone
erkrankung bei den auf normalstation
hospitalisierten patienten den patienten
ist das schon eher gemischt also da sind
etwa die hälfte wegen einer saß kauf
zwei infektionen aber
ungefähr die hälfte sind wegen anderer
dinge ins krankenhaus gekommen und dann
ist zaz kauf zweier infektion
festgestellt worden und diese
wochenlange erfahren jetzt wie wird
wirken sich diese hohen wasser sagen die
höchsten neuinfektionen die wir in
dieser ganzen pandemie jemals
kennengelernt haben bundesweit verbunden
mit denen dann hohen 7 tages in
sequenzen wie wirken die sich auf die
leistungsfähigkeit des gesundheitswesens
aus da muss man einfach sagen anders als
bei delta bei alpha oder beim wildtyp
fallen hier diese anzahl der
neuinfektionen
und die daraus abgeleiteten 7 tages
inzidenz von der belastung der kliniken
vollkommen auseinander
und genau das stimmt uns
vorsichtig optimistisch dass wir zwar
nicht wie im nachbarland dänemark von
heute auf morgen sagen pandemie ist
vorbei und jetzt fahren wir sämtliche
maßnahmen oder fast alle maßnahmen auf
einen schlag zurück sondern ich plädiere
eindringlich dafür dass wir schritt für
schritt maßnahmen zurückfahren und das
schleswig-holstein hamburg bremen
die länder sind die
zuallererst davon betroffen waren das
sieht man jetzt in diesen bundesländern
sinken selbst die instanzen von denen
ich allerdings sagt dass sie kaum noch
einen geeigneten parameter zur
beurteilung der gesamtsituation
darstellen das tut vielmehr die
sogenannte hospitalisierung incidents
die wir uns allerdings in schleswig
holstein nicht alleine verlassen sondern
wir gucken uns wirklich jeden tag an wie
viele patienten werden hospitalisiert
beziehungsweise sind hospitalisiert wie
viele davon sind auf der intensivstation
wie viele von denen die auf
intensivstationen sind werden invasiv
beatmet und hier gucken uns unsere
impfquoten an und in dieser gesamtschau
betrachtet beginnen wir oder wollen wir
ein prozess beginnen auf der einen seite
die debatte anzustoßen
wir müssen gegen übergang von pandemisch
auf endemisch schaffen also das lernen
mit dem virus zu leben und gleichzeitig
schritt für schritt behutsam vorsichtig
und nicht übermütig
schritte in die normalität zu wagen das
sind wir nicht nur den menschen schuldig
ich glaube das sind wir auch unserer
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
wir sind dieser hier verpflichtet weil
ich mir ehrlicherweise im moment
mindestens genauso viele sorgen darüber
macht was diese pandemie das bisherige
pandemie management mit unserer
gesellschaft macht ich habe unglaublich
hohen respekt vor dem medizinerinnen und
medizinern vor den virologen die uns ja
auch beraten als landesregierung aber
wir müssen auch sehen welche schäden
auch pandemie eindämmen de maßnahmen die
am anfang schulschließungen kita
schließungen und andere für unsere
kinder und jugendlichen beispielsweise
hatten und das muss man zwei jahre
in der wir jetzt in dieser pandemie
leben mit instrumenten wie wir sie am
anfang nicht hatten nämlich impfstoffe
antivirale therapien und ein größeres
wissen würde mir wünschen die datenlage
wir in deutschland noch eine bessere
wenn ich da nach dänemark oder auch in
die vereinigten staaten mir die
täglichen daten der cdc anguckt kann man
noch eine ganze menge von lernen aber
ich glaube wir müssen heute under ein
anderes pandemie management betreiben
als wir es zu beginn der pandemie oder
auch während der del tabelle gemacht
haben wir wollen das jetzt gleich mal
weiten und auch noch in weiteren
gesprächspartner dazu bitten aber jetzt
gerade nochmal zu diesem punkt mit einer
bitte um kurze antwort wegen der
voranschreitenden zeit jetzt ist ja auch
nicht ganz unwichtig im mai wird in
schleswig holstein gewählt und noch ein
paar anderen bundesländern und gerade
das was sie ebenso betont haben dass
hatte man jetzt von der fdp auch länger
so deutlicher auch nicht gehört als es
um die ampel koalitionsverhandlungen
gegen ist es jetzt auch noch mal gerade
wichtig dass jetzt also vor so einer
landtagswahl zu betont und gerne kurze
antwort ja das werden jetzt meine
parteifreunde parteifreunde vielleicht
nicht so gerne hören dass ich als
landesvorsitzender sagte ich bin in
dieser pandemie nach wie vor
gesundheitsminister des landes schleswig
holstein und deswegen zuallererst dem
wohle des landes verpflichtet das ist
für mich keine frage von
landtagswahlkämpfen egal wann sie
stattfinden sondern das ist für mich
eine frage
wie gehen wir wollen wir in zukunft als
gesamtgesellschaftlich freiheitlich
demokratisch zusammenleben und das
möchte ich nicht gefährdet sehen und
deswegen die landtagswahl haben wir im
blick aber das pandemie management
richtet sich nicht nach
landtagswahltermin das virus übrigens
auch nicht und jetzt schauen wir mal
weiter auf diese zukunft auf die wir
also alle gemeinsam auch jenseits von
schleswig holstein im blick müssen
können sollen sie haben es vorsichtig
optimistisch genannt jetzt schauen wir
doch mal die optimistisch wir vielleicht
auch alle sein können wenn wir die
zukunft blicken es gibt also
modellrechnungen die zeigen wie sich da
die aktuelle welle entwickelt also hier
wurde im prinzip berechnet wie kann es
aussehen wenn die omikron welle
voranschreitet wann wird sie
voraussichtlich ihren höhepunkt
erreichen mitte februar zeigt uns das
modell also in einem mittleren sie
nennen ist das wahrscheinlichste
szenario könnte die inzidenz bis dahin
das ist aber schon beachtlich dort noch
ungefähr doppelt so hoch steigen wie in
den vergangenen tagen und da hat man
sich auch so ein bisschen gerichtet wohl
auch an den berechnungen wie man sie aus
großbritannien zum beispiel kennt wo die
welle eben bereits schon früher
ausgebrochen ist und dazu können wir
jetzt auch sprechen mit thorsten lernen
möchte gerne mit ins boot zu holen bei
mir auf dem obst wenn es bei euch
genauso unangenehm ist und jetzt ist es
weg
da war also so lässt sich besser reden
ohne thiesson auf dem arm thorsten leer
herzlich willkommen er modelliert corona
zahlen kennt sich damit also bestens aus
ist professor an der universität des
saarlandes hallo hallo wunderschönen
folgen jetzt haben wir gerade eben so
eine modellrechnung gesehen die also
einen peak von so einer welle im mitte
februar voraus sagt das ist bald wie
verlässlich sind da solche
modellrechnungen dieser zahlen ja man
muss sagen da gibt es natürlich eine
menge einflussfaktoren die hier auch
eine rolle spielen die simulation die
sie da gerade gesehen haben sind schon
ein bisschen älter und gehen halt davon
aus dass ich manche dinge auch mit der
gleichen geschwindigkeit mit einer
gewissen verhältnismäßigkeit in die
zukunft fortsetzen hier ist sicherlich
auch davon ausgegangen dass die
impfquote beispielsweise weiter steigt
ähnlich wie sie auch im dezember wochen
gegangen ist das ist zum beispiel ein
wichtiger faktor es kommt ja noch ein
faktor mit hinzu dass beispielsweise die
saisonalitäten rolle spielt das heißt
das wetter und das klima was jetzt auch
wieder besser wird was uns im winter
ihre probleme bereitet hat haben jetzt
wieder rückenwind was die infektions
lage angeht also da sind ein paar
stellschrauben und ich glaube wir dürfen
nicht vergessen was ne rolle spielt ist
natürlich auch die psyche des menschen
beziehungsweise bevölkerung das heißt
wir sehen natürlich oft auch wenn wir
waren vor gewissen situationen das dann
auch entsprechender weise gehandelt wird
entweder von der politik oder eben auch
von der bevölkerung der sich zurücknimmt
also da gibt es viele einflussfaktoren
die solche berechnung und vorhersagen
beeinflussen können deswegen sprechen
wir auch über von szenarien und ich
unbedingt von einer vorhersage weil wir
dann eben gewisse annahmen treffen die
ihn so modell mit einfließen und so ein
szenario
oder ist das möglich damit sie auch
gehört was herr karg im prinzip du ihm
gesagt hat was bei schleswig holstein
jetzt auch ab mittwoch passiert also ein
paar sachen werden gelockert in dem
falle kein zweig mehr im einzelhandel
wie optimistisch sind sie noch wenn sie
jetzt also hören es gibt ja mehrere
bundesländer die also jetzt die ersten
lockerungsschritte jetzt schon gehen ja
ich glaube es ist richtig dass wir jetzt
über lockerung sprechen ich glaube wir
können nicht weiter über verschärfender
maßnahmen reden wir müssen gucken wie
wir jetzt mit dieser familie leben das
ist richtig wir müssen sehen dass wir
wirklich in den einzelnen bundesländern
ganz unterschiedliche situation haben
herr görg hat in schleswig-holstein
wirklich eine sehr gute komfortable
situation dazu kann man immer noch
gratulieren das ist toll wenn dort eine
sehr niedrigen zins bezieher relativ
gesehen halten sie eben noch oben die
1000 knapp unter 1000 schon längere zeit
werden sie in anderen bundesländern
gerade eben erst ansteigt oder in den
letzten wochen sehr stark gestiegen ist
ich glaube da muss man aufpassen dass
man nicht in jedem bundesland eigentlich
gleich reagieren kann wir dürfen nicht
vergessen egal inwieweit wir locker und
lockerungen bedeutet eigentlich immer
mehr kontakte bedeutet mehr infektionen
das gilt es jetzt eigentlich erstmal zu
verhindern vor allem weil wir uns ja
jetzt auf diesem weg zu bewegen und das
würde wie herr lauterbach schon gesagt
hat und das zeigen auch unsere modelle
eigentlich daraus resultieren dass die
fallzahlen weiter steigen können
natürlich tut sich im moment
offensichtlich erst mit den kliniken
nicht viel aber wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass viele delta patienten
jetzt auch erstmal sozusagen
ausgewaschen sind aus den kliniken und
jetzt sehen wir auch wieder steigende
neue einweisung letztendlich in den
kliniken durch auch mikron die zwar ein
bisschen bilder sind aber von grund der
hohen fallzahlen halt eben doch
auftreten also das passiert schon was
ich glaube wir müssen einfach ein
bisschen vorsichtig sein wichtig ist für
mich halt eben dass wir da richtig
kommunizieren man kann mit den
lockerungen letztendlich machen nicht
was man will aber man kann relativ viel
machen man muss einfach mit den
konsequenzen leben und meine sorge ist
die kommunikation dass sie einheitlich
ist und auch so dass der bürger und die
bürgerin auch wirklich versteht warum
das gemacht wird und dass man eben auch
notfalls wenn die maßnahmen es erfordern
oder die situation ist erfordert
maßnahmen auch wieder zurücknehmen ich
glaube da ist kommunikativ muss sehr
viel getan werden da ist viel vertrauen
verloren gegangen und da sehe ich jetzt
die schwierigkeit auch das jetzt
brötchen weise hier gelockert wird ich
glaube nicht dass dieser wandel des
wegfall des zwerges jetzt wirklich eine
explosion in den fallzahlen hervorruft
aber es wird natürlich sony rotieren
sein was stattfindet an verschiedenen
stellen und dann wird genau was
wegfallen da noch was wegfallen ich
glaube das ist dann einfach so ein
gewisses brocken was einst etwas härter
war sicherlich verhindern will und wo
wir jetzt aufpassen müssen wird das glas
nicht zu früh einsetzt damit wir über
diesen berg und auch rüberkommen und
dann auch wirklich die fahrt ins tal und
in den frühling genießen können ich
würde gerne ein paar kommentare aus dem
stream mitzunehmen bis in die stimmung
widerspiegeln von unseren userinnen und
usern ehrenmann bei youtube schreibt man
kann für lockerungen sein und trotzdem
vorsichtig sein beispielsweise oder
ich habe hier noch ein kommentar von
liese pomper sie schreibt ich würde mir
ein wenig lockerungen wünschen bin
selbst geimpft aber nach zwei jahren
auch corona müde und dann aber auch gibt
es natürlich auch andere stimmen zum
beispiel terrys berger roman schreibt
bei facebook ich finde die lockeren
lockerungen sind vollkommen überstürzt
wenn natürlich so viele menschen in
manchen bundesländern geimpft sind ist
das was anderes trotz einem wurde auf
der pressekonferenz gesagt dass die
pandemie bei nicht genügender impfung in
ganz deutschland neue varianten
wahrscheinlich verursachen wird herr lee
und herr gauck zu ihnen komme ich gleich
noch mit einer rückfrage nachfrager weil
er erst kurz die frage wie
wahrscheinlich ist das denn das also
dann doch vielleicht neue varianten sich
noch wieder ausbilden können ja es ist
wirklich schwierig das mit einer
statistischen wahrscheinlichkeit zu
belegen wir haben es jetzt gesehen dass
ein gewisser regelmäßigkeit immer neue
varianten um die ecke gekommen sind und
ich halte es für gar nicht
ausgeschlossen dass auch ihrem nächsten
noch und seine neue variante behörden
will oder weil wir haben sehr hohe in
sidenten weltweit haben wir eigentlich
die massivsten infektionen und dass ich
hier jetzt eigentlich auch ein ganz
guter varianten filter auftut dadurch
dass wir viele geimpfte haben und eben
ganz viele infektionen halte ich für
nicht sehr unwahrscheinlich die frage
wird sein was wird das für eine variante
sein das lässt sich einfach nicht
vorhersagen ob sie wirklich sich weiter
abschwächt wie das bis jetzt vielleicht
geschehen ist oder ob sie dann noch mal
schlimmer wird es gibt auch diskussionen
beziehungsweise vermutungen die sagen
wenn omikron durch ist könnte delta
nochmal wiederkommen also ich glaube es
gibt viele szenarien dann noch mal
auftreten können das müssen wir uns
letztendlich bewusstsein aber mit einer
wahrscheinlichkeit kann das niemand
wirklich seriös sagen was auftritt
vielleicht auch keine mehr vielleicht
bleibt es bei unicredit werden es leider
sehen müssen
vergab sie hatten das angesprochen zuvor
dass sie in schleswig-holstein
tatsächlich sie gehören zu also dem
oberen drittel wenn es ums impfen geht
stehen da also gut da als bundesland
haben sie aber sorge dass jetzt
natürlich eine lockerung stichwort
wieder zum beispiel zwei geben
einzelhandel vielleicht auch ein
falsches signal senden könnte an all
jene die man ja noch vom impfen
überzeugen wollte
ja ich habe in dieser pandemie gelernt
das ist eigentlich egal was du machst
meistens ist
der eine teil finde es richtig der
anteil findet falsch damit wird man
leben müssen das gehört zum
tagesgeschäft dazu wir haben in
schleswig holstein gott sei dank eine
bevölkerung die
nicht impfmüde ist und ich habe schon
den eindruck dass die angebote die wir
gemacht haben die wir weitermachen
werden
zielgruppenspezifische niedrigschwellige
angebote dass die dazu geführt haben zu
seiner hohen impfquote ich will mal
wirklich auch meinen dank aussprechen an
die vielen jungen leute wir haben eine
impfquote bundesweit
absolut an der spitze bei den 12 bis 17
jährigen die liegt bei rund 73 prozent
vollständig geimpften 12 bis 17 jährigen
und wenn ich eine andere bundesländer
guckt die die gerade die hälfte
ausweisen von dieser impfquote natürlich
mache ich mir sorgen weil ich weiß dass
diese republik nicht mehr ausschließlich
holstein also dem land zwischen den
meeren besteht und ich glaube nach wie
vor sowie das professor lehr ja auch
ausgeführt hat
wir wissen einfach nicht kommt delta
möglicherweise noch mal zurück gibt es
eine neue variante ist die neue variante
noch ansteckender und ungefährlicher
oder ist sie noch ansteckender und viele
pathogene da wir das nicht wissen halte
ich nach wie vor das impfen für eine der
wichtigsten aufgaben im übrigen auch für
eine der wichtigsten staatlichen
aufgaben selbst wenn wir den übergang
von pandemischer endemisch gestalten
bedeutet dass definitiv dass wir eine
impfkampagne vielleicht auch noch mal
ein bisschen ansprechender als das was
wir bisher deutschlandweit hatten da war
da ein andere länder guckt sieht man
dass man es auch ein bisschen ich sag
mal ein bisschen mehr sexy machen kann
als ärmel hochkrempeln
und auch maßnahmen wie beispielsweise
das masken tragen in vielen settings wo
viele leute zusammenkommen davon bin ich
überzeugt dass uns das noch eine ganze
weile erhalten bleibt ich halte gar
nichts davon den leuten zu versprechen
dass mit irgendeinem tag ist kann sich
die maske vom gesicht reißen und impfen
ist auch nicht mehr so wichtig und
ansonsten können sie wieder tun was ihr
wollt das wäre unsinn und das wäre auch
unverantwortlich
aber schritt für schritt menschen wieder
die grundrechts einschränkt die wir ja
als mittel der gefahrenabwehr haben das
ist ja ein instrument des
infektionsschutzgesetzes von dem
gebrauch gemacht wurde und von dem ich
ja auch überhaupt nicht gezögert habe 23
monate gebrauch zu machen um die
menschen in schleswig holstein zu
schützen aber es gehört auch dazu dass
politikerinnen und politiker sehr klar
sagen dass wir unsere gesundheitssysteme
vor überlastung schützen müssen wir
würden uns wirklich anmaßen oder dass er
eine anmaßung zu behaupten wir könnten
jeden menschen vor einer infektion
schützen das wird nicht der fall sein
und das kann auch nicht das ziel von
pandemie management sein sondern wir
müssen diese dinge glaube ich jetzt
offene ansprechen als das in der
vergangenheit der fall gewesen ist um
die menschen wirklich wieder mitzunehmen
ich glaube im übrigen auch nicht dass
von all den menschen die sich in
schleswig-holstein noch nicht haben
impfen lassen das sind so pummelig
350.000 etwa
mal diejenigen die sich nicht impfen
lassen können weil sie jünger als 5 sind
oder weil medizinische gründe dagegen
sprechen das sind mit sicherheit nicht
alles radikale impfgegner sondern dass
die menschen die angst haben die sorge
haben ob die begründet oder unbegründet
sind spielt überhaupt keine rolle wir
müssen sie überzeugen wir kriegen jetzt
einen dritten impfstoff zu dem mrsa und
rektor basierten impfstoff ganz gut dass
ich kurz nachfragen bei jahre 2 geben
einzelhandel war sie haben's ja
instrument genannt war das nicht
vielleicht auch ein instrument um quasi
zu überzeugen mensch lasst euch impfen
weil sonst könnt ihr hier nicht mehr
teilnehmen und ist das dann also
gescheitert ehrlicherweise ist doch dass
eine ausgrenzung von nicht geimpften
menschen gewesen und da muss man sich
überlegen wie lange will man eigentlich
so eine maßnahme vor allem wenn sie von
zahlreichen gerichten in deutschland
gekippt wird wie lange will man so eine
maßnahme aufrechterhalten ich bin froh
dass wir jetzt hoffentlich ende februar
kriegen dann dritten impfstoff also den
protein basierten impfstoff nowaks den
implementieren wir sofort in unsere
impfkampagnen schleswig-holstein
priorisieren zuallererst mal die
menschen die sich aus medizinischen
gründen nicht mit den vektor basierten
impfstoff oder mit einem impfstoff haben
impfen lassen können und
selbstverständlich all diejenigen für
die eine einrichtung bezogen impfpflicht
gilt und dann wollen wir gucken dass wir
so schnell wie möglich auch allen
anderen die sich dafür interessieren und
entscheiden wollen diesen impfstoff zur
verfügung stellen können da haben wir
drei verschiedene impfstoff typen mit
unterschiedlichen eigenschaften und noch
mal vielleicht ja auch noch mal der
appell auch von den ländern an den bund
gleich gelingt es uns ja zusammen eine
impfkampagne nochmal er so zu fahren wie
es die franzosen beispielsweise gemacht
haben mit etwas ansprechen darin motiven
und auch ein bisschen augen zwingen kann
noch mal dass es gelingen kann menschen
anzusprechen ich glaube das hat man in
schleswig-holstein gerade bei den jungen
menschen gesehen das sind 12 bis 17
jährigen haben sich viele jedenfalls
diejenigen die so ab 14.15 selbstständig
auch eine entscheidung getroffen haben
ganz bewusst fürs impfen entschieden
sehr verantwortungsbewusst das sind das
ist eine impfquote die haben in manch
anderen ländern in manch anderen
bundesländern die 60 jahre alten eltern
mich erreicht dass nutzer sich
vorstellen im moment gelingt eine sache
tatsächlich auf bundesebene schon mal
nicht so gut und zwar stichwort
einrichtungs bezogen im pflicht da gibt
es also eine diskussion heute drüber er
hat sich also der bayerische
ministerpräsident markus söder geäußert
hat gesagt nach derzeitigem stand sieht
er da also wenig chancen auf eine
umsetzung dieser einrichtungs bezogenen
impfpflicht und dazu haben wir in kurzen
beitrag indem wir gemeinsam rein schauen
wollen von britta buchholz
es ist gerade mal acht wochen her als
die abgeordneten die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht beschlossen nicht
nur die ampel parteien auch die union
stimmte dafür jetzt die kehrtwende der
csu chef söder will einen bayerischen
sonderweg die beschlossene impfpflicht
soll vorerst nicht kommen uns geht es
allein darum die pflegenden nicht allein
zu lassen und nicht am ende dadurch an
den pflegenotstand zu bekommen nur weil
ein gesetz schlampig vorbereitet ist
vorbereitet wurde das gesetz auch in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz auch dort
rang sie um eine gemeinsame lösung die
empörung über den kursschwenk der union
ist groß
das schlägt ehrlich dem fass den boden
aus die abkehr der einrichtungs
bezogenen impfpflicht ist aus meiner
sicht verantwortungslos und auch
rücksichtslose parteipolitische taktik
das ziel war klar das personal in
kliniken arztpraxen oder altenheim
sollte geimpft oder genesen sein zum
schutz der schwächsten die sorge um
personalschwund gab es schon immer
eigentlich haben wir keine neuen fakten
an dieser stelle von anfang an war klar
dass es natürlich auch bei der umsetzung
probleme und herausforderungen geben
würde an den muss gearbeitet werden
aber jeder verantwortungsbewusste
politiker muss wissen dass geltendes
recht geltendes recht ist muss das als
allererstes sagen was der kursschwenk
für die impfpflicht für pflegekräfte
bedeutet ist fraglich sie sollte in
gerade mal fünf wochen beginnen
das klingt jetzt auch schon wieder eher
nach chaos und er unheil
uneinheitlichkeit auf bundesebene wie
ist es bei ihnen in schleswig-holstein
hergab sie machen mit sie wollen das
umsetzen also markus söder war wenn ich
mal dran erinnern darf der erste ist ja
immer so sonderwege bekannt die
irgendwie kommuniziert der erste der
eine einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
gefordert hat nun hat er sie mit
beschlossen ja irgendwie und jetzt will
er sie nicht umsetzen dass es erstens
bemerkenswert weil auch in bayern glaube
das ist teil der bundesrepublik
deutschland bundesrecht umzusetzen ist
und zweitens ist es genauso wie malu
dreyer sagt billigste parteipolitische
profilierung und zwar in einer der
schwierigsten phasen dieser pandemie
kann man machen muss man aber nicht
machen wir in schleswig holstein und
zwar auch der cdu ministerpräsident hat
das klipp und klar heute auch der
öffentlichkeit gesagt wir werden
selbstverständlich alles daran setzen
die einrichtungs bezogen impfpflicht
umzusetzen ja das ist eine
herausforderung vielleicht in schleswig
holstein nicht ganz so schwierig wie in
manch anderen bundesländern weil ich
nicht davon ausgeht dass die impfquote
bei den pflegekräften und dem
medizinischen bereich signifikant unter
der durchschnittsquote liegt aber es
bleibt eine herausforderung wir sind mit
allen beteiligten auf allen ebenen in
gesprächen und verhandlungen um diese
impfpflicht umzusetzen und mein ziel ist
dass das so zu gestalten dass es
natürlich im zweifel auch eine gewisse
übergangszeit für diejenigen gibt die
jetzt noch nicht geimpft oder nur einmal
geimpft sind das die die möglichkeit
haben
sich noch impfen zu lassen und dann der
die immunisierung auch eintritt auch mit
dem angebot des neuen protein basierten
impfstoff aber wo kommen wir eigentlich
da hin wenn wir alle gemeinsam
miteinander uns auf eine wie ich finde
fachlich begründete und vernünftige
maßnahme entscheiden und dann
tanz einer aus der reihe der ja
ehrlicherweise in den letzten 24 oder 23
monaten vor allem dadurch aufgefallen
ist dass er immer am lautesten war
allerdings wenn ich es mal so sagen darf
ja nicht zwingend mit der besten
pandemie bilanz bislang auf wartet also
ich finds ehrlicherweise ziemlich
daneben was da gestern passiert ist viel
eher wenn wir ein bisschen weggehen von
auch dem der politischen
auseinandersetzung wir haben eine
nachricht per mail bekommen die würde
ich gerne knapp vor lesen und dann eine
rückfrage ansieht und zwar schreibt
herr oder frau schilling das kann ich
gerade nicht genau sehen pfleger
krankenschwestern arzthelfer innen die
ebenfalls zwei jahre durch die pandemie
gerungen haben die kurve longo wird aber
auch nebenwirkungen und
langzeiterkrankungen aufgrund der
impfung sehen mussten sind keine corona
leugner oder generelle impfkritiker aber
wenn sie sich trotzdem wissentlich für
ihre sie nennt es oder er nennt es
unversehrtheit und ihr natürliches
immunsystem entscheiden wie man ihnen
jetzt den arbeitsplatz wegnehmen
wenn sie das ganze sie schauen ja auch
ein bisschen darauf was könnte uns
blühen also jetzt in den nächsten wochen
und wie geht alles weiter wenn sie
darauf schauen und das würde also jetzt
nicht kommen quasi eine eine impfpflicht
und es würden also nach wie vor sich
einfach nicht mehr menschen impfen
lassen das bliebe alles relativ beim
status quo landen wir dann
ja das ist natürlich wirklich schwierig
zu sagen aber ein problem was sich
sicherlich sehe ist dass wir hier einmal
nicht geimpfte personen auf sehr gute
gruppen zu loslassen und wir dürfen
nicht vergessen im moment ist die
inzidenz die altersbezogene inzidenz bei
den über 80-jährigen extrem niedrig dies
nur ein viertel so hoch wie im
bundesdeutschen schnitt noch bei den
über 60 jährigen ist sie generell nur so
ungefähr ein drittel so die älteren die
wohl den schützen sich momentan sehr gut
das liegt ein bisschen dran dass die
infektion jetzt vor allem aus der jugend
über die jugend in die familien hinein
getragen werden aber noch nicht so sehr
in die älteren personen rein
personengruppen rein und ich habe sehr
große sorgen dass wir jetzt hier mit
omikron die natürlich eine variante die
sich sehr leicht verbreitet und dann
auch leicht übertragbar ist hier
sicherlich wieder szenarien schaffen in
den einrichtungen die wir auf keinen
fall haben wollen ich glaube wir müssen
einfach schauen warum sich diese ja
diese dieser teile der der pflegenden
gesellschaftlich nicht nicht impfen
lassen will wir müssen kommunikation
suchen das ist deutlich mehr als in
anderen ländern ist aber ich habe schon
wirklich sorgen wenn man das nicht
umsetzt dass es hier vor allem bei den
bei den raben gruppen möglich probleme
geben könnte die wir wirklich nicht
haben wollen wir können im moment froh
sein wie gesagt dass die instanzen dort
zu niedrig sind das ist auch ein grund
dafür warum und momentan so gut dastehen
aber
wir müssen ja weiter gucken dass wir zum
einen natürlich die wohl der
rebellengruppen auch weiter impfen das
wird die eine seite sein aber halt eben
auch diejenigen die dort mit denen
tagtäglich zugange sind dann müssen wir
einfach dass die infektion eingetragen
werden und auch übertragen und das muss
einfach verhindert werden und zwar auch
durch impfung
so jetzt zum schluss noch eine frage ich
sagte natürlich schon mal vielen dank
aber auch gleich noch mal aber herr
lehrer an sie schon mal vielen dank dass
ich gerne von ihnen zum schluss noch
wissen möchte herr gab also nächste
woche beraten die länderchefs mit der
bundesregierung jetzt im prinzip sind
die länder ja schon mit einigen
entscheidungen vorgedrungen was passiert
denn dann noch nächste woche
naja schleswig holstein das hatte ich ja
vorhin schon mal ausgeführt schließlich
deutschland hat sich mit den maßnahmen
die wir jetzt morgen auf den weg bringen
falls noch im rahmen der letzten mpk
also beschlüsse der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz bewegt ich
erwarte und ich würde mir das von dieser
mpk ein signal ausgeht dass wir die
diskussion die ich am anfang sehr
umfänglich beschrieben habe dass wir die
führen wie bereiten wir die menschen auf
einen übergang von einer pandemischen
auf eine endemische situation vor wie
bereiten wir die menschen die bisher von
der politik gewohnt waren je höher die
instanzen desto drastischer die
maßnahmen die genau denselben menschen
denen wir 23 monate erklären mussten und
erklären wollten warum wir genauso
vorgehen den müssen wir jetzt erklären
warum wir gerade auf dem höhepunkt
der inzidenz der es bundesweit weiß ich
noch nicht erreicht aber gerade bei so
hohen instanzen bei so hohen fall sein
warum wir jetzt genau diese diskussion
führen weil wir eine andere situation
haben weil wir andere instrumente haben
als noch zum glück als noch vor einem
oder vor anderthalb jahren und dieses
signal das wünsche ich mir von der mpk
mir geht es gar nicht so sehr um
einzelmaßnahmen da kann man über vieles
reden also über kontakt beschränkungen
für geimpfte beispielsweise wir haben in
schleswig holstein wie in vielen
bundesländern nach wie vor relativ
strenge kontakt beschränkung auch für
dreifach geimpfte menschen dass es
vielleicht auch eher einen
motivationskick
aber jenseits von einzelmaßnahmen glaube
ich ist das oder wären mir das
wichtigste dass diese generelle
diskussionsbereitschaft dass dieses
generelle signal von dieser mpk ausgeht
wir müssen jetzt die menschen darauf
vorbereiten dass wir mit diesem virus
wahrscheinlich die nächsten jahre
vielleicht nach dem nächsten jahrzehnte
lernen leben lernen müssen und das
bitteschön in freiheit
sagt heiner garg der gesundheitsminister
in schleswig-holstein vielen dank für
heute abend und auch vielen dank an
thorsten der professor an der
universität des saarlandes schön dass
wir unsere gäste waren danke danke danke
schön und
natürlich auch danke für eure
aufmerksamkeit und wir beobachten
natürlich auch nächste woche das treffen
zwischen bund und ländern und auch
dazwischen sind wir natürlich für euch
live bis dahin tschüss